Incredible claims have surfaced from former
national security advisor, John Bolton.
And um, it is now believed that John Bolton
regularly questioned whether Donald Trump
was acting in the best interests of the United
States.
It's an almost unbelievable revelation, but
I want to be careful using that language.
I've said before, when we say you won't believe
the next thing, Donald Trump data, the last
thing Donald Trump did.
It does in a sense, maybe implicitly foment
a lack of belief that this is the real world.
So I want to be careful about using those
terms.
The new battle lines and impeachment as we've
talked about are Ken Donald Trump's former
national security advisor, John Bolton be
trusted.
John Bolton says in his upcoming book that
Donald Trump personally told him, withhold
the military aid to Ukraine until Ukraine
announces the smear investigations into Joe
Biden.
Democrats want John Bolton to testify in Donald
Trump's impeachment trial.
Republicans seemingly do not.
They are smearing John Bolton as a tool of
the radical left on Fox business.
That was Lou Dobbs.
We played those clips earlier for you.
Eventually probably Friday the Senate will
vote as to whether they are going to call
witnesses and whether John Bolton is going
to be one of those witnesses.
Now, Republicans don't want him to testify
despite saying, Hey, we would love some firsthand
accounts as part of this impeachment trial,
and despite John Bolton being able to provide
exactly that, Republicans don't want him to
testify.
So now it is all about can we really trust
John Bolton to tell the truth and every single
day, this is what they say.
By the way, every single day we hear from
a more from John Bolton, which tells me we
have to hear from him in the Senate trial.
It is an absolute imperative that we hear
from John Bolton.
More revelations now from John Bolton's upcoming
book reveal that when Bolton was Donald Trump's
national security advisor, that relative relatively
brief period, Bolton was regularly appalled.
That's a quote regularly appalled by the behavior
of Donald Trump and that John Bolton's sometimes
couldn't tell whether Trump was acting based
on doing what's best for the United States
or on other nefarious goals.
And nefarious is Bolton's word not mine.
Let me say it again.
In other words, because we are all desensitized
to the insanity of the political status quo.
In 2020 the national security advisor of the
United States, when he was in that position,
would watch the president's actions, would
observe the decisions of the president and
doubted or could not tell.
Is the president acting with the interests
of the United States in mind, or does the
president have other nefarious interests in
mind when he makes these decisions?
This is not normal.
Even if Bolton was wrong in his assessment,
the fact that Bolton couldn't tell in whose
interests Donald Trump was acting is in and
of itself a scandal.
Now, let me be very clear.
John Bolton is one of the worst reactionary
right-wing pro war neo-cons of the last 20
years, but I don't believe John Bolton would
show up and just lie under oath to the Senate.
The way it's being portrayed now by some on
the right is that you can't believe this guy,
Lou Dobbs saying he's a tool of the radical
left.
He's linked to Veneman and Romney and all
of these conspiracy theories that Lou Dobbs
literally charted out with a spider map connections.
As I showed you earlier, I don't believe Bolton
will would show up and lie.
Donald Trump is already asserting that John
Bolton is simply lying.
A Donald Trump tweeted in direct contradiction
to John Bolton's claim quote, I never told
John Bolton that the aid to Ukraine was tied
to investigations into Democrats, including
the Bidens.
In fact, he never complained about this at
the time of his very public termination that
proves nothing.
Of course, if John Bolton said this, it was
only to sell a book.
Now, of course, John Bolton may not have said
this at the time of his termination because
it was not immediately relevant.
Now that that is the subject of impeachment,
it is not a farfetched to believe that John
Bolton is hearing lies.
Being told, recognizes he has knowledge about
this and says, well, no, now I actually have
something to add.
Now I want to show up and I want to testify.
Uh, we are not dealing with good people when
we talk about Donald Trump.
And John Bolton, but Trump lies endlessly
about everything all the time, including insignificant
things.
So if you ask me who do I believe here, I
believe John Bolton and I challenge anyone
to make a strong case for why Donald Trump
is more believable here than John Bolton.
John Bolton.
Okay.
He might want to sell a book, right?
That's the motivation.
Donald Trump has been impeached and the entire
case arguing against the reason for his impeachment
is arguably completely dissolved by the testimony
of John Bolton.
Bolton might want to sell some books.
Okay.
Is that going to make John Bolton just show
up and lie under oath to the Senate?
I don't believe so.
Donald Trump has his presidency at stake and
is the longtime historically proven liar.
Doesn't mean Bolton is anything other than
an architect of the Iraq war.
But John Bolton was a guy who was the darling
of the neo-con pro Iraq war right wing for
more than a decade.
And because he says, I know what the, you
know, I have a story to tell.
Uh, what's being said publicly isn't true.
I will show up and I will tell the story.
He is now being trashed by the administration,
by Republican officials, by right wing media
like Lou Dobbs on Fox business, all to try
to either prevent him from testifying altogether
if he testifies, make him not believed or
appear to be not credible.
It's embarrassing and we are going to continue
talking about this and we will know sooner
than later whether we are actually going to
hear testimony, um, from John Bolton.
I hope that the answer is yes.
Let me know what
you believe.
Do you believe that we will ultimately hear
testimony from John Bolton in Donald Trump's
Senate impeachment trial, the David Pakman
show